[Music]
let's talk about bella thorne
you guys know who she is yes no oh i
kept thinking
it was bella defean she was ex disney
channel stuff yes
she was in shake it up with uh diet yeah
didn't she do something fast
that's what we're talking about okay she
is
celebrity status right so when she
joined only fans
she ended up breaking records because
she i think she earned a million
in one day in a day yeah and then two
million in less than a week
doing what she showed a [ __ ] so that's
the thing
uh she said that she was not going to be
doing any nudes but then at one point
she
she was charging two hundred dollars for
nudes
to her something around 50 000
subscribers and it turned out that they
weren't nudes it was just
so then they started bombarding this
company
for refunds i'd be pissed too so she
said it was nudes
uh yeah like she labeled it nudes that
ain't even new
she's wearing a nude bikini and maybe
that's or not bikini but
it's like nude fabric well they she was
wearing lingerie
so that's not that's lingerie that's not
new to ray
yeah and then no naked to be
nude you have to see both nipples both
because even if it's just one like this
i don't even consider this that's a
giant jacket somebody blur it out
that's art that's art if it's one nipple
it's a cyclops
if it's two that's a nude that's nude
well would you need vagina in order
oh yeah that's a nude extra credit
bonus oh really so all you need is two
nipples
so if you're if you're topless if you're
doing a full shot like this from head to
toe
yeah like if she's doing a sexy mug shot
themed campaign or whatever if she
covers her nipples you have to see
her [ __ ] or her ass crap yeah there's
balance but if her [ __ ] is covered then
you need both nipples yup isn't that
just topless
that would that would be this is nice
nude i'd say
in a spread i would say it has to be a
collection
yes right you can't just have all
topless photos and just call it
it's that's that's not full nude that's
like this like this right if she's like
this
and then so you have one two three four
four golden spots
right if she covers one of them and she
shows the other three i think that's
cool too
three out of the four golden spots needs
to be that's true that's true but she
never said full nude
probably or i didn't see exactly how she
labeled it but um
is this considered the arm
yeah i want is it because when you start
charging for individual photos is it
because there's an automated message
that's like
this is a nude it goes out to all
subscribers yeah so is it just like
that's just the automated thing
i don't know i have to charge for this
photo now rather than the overall
subscription i don't use only fan so
that's a good
insider i need to sign up i haven't made
one yet i need to make one i just
yeah i'm ready you should the world
isn't ready though
but do it anyway we're all ready you
should just show the bottom of your feet
i got a wart right now that's why oh and
it's just
dark like really dirty i'm meaning to
deal with it
i've been having it for three years what
the [ __ ] okay
it hasn't gone away it's what's going to
fall off like that man's penis
you know that's contagious warts
oh and he's been barefoot you touch the
barefoot thing with your bare feet
i don't care bart already has a
different kind of wart yeah
yes highly convenient he doesn't have
foot fungus
i have two toenails that have like
permanent fungus me too whoa
hello camera you're still trying to
relate
you see it it looks weird it looks like
[ __ ] eagle claw talons
claw they look disgusting is it a
different color i can't see from yeah
it's hard and it like it's like way
thicker and it gets brittle
oh like old people talk did you know
that you got a podiatrist
i just went to one yesterday my cousin's
becoming one i'll see him in a year
oh can i just go to him me too i'm
trying to go to him
i'll deal with this for another year so
then by the time oh my gosh
is that it no this is a blister oh that
looks crazy
it's like that's already gross there's a
lot of different colors down there i'm
not sure what's going on
it just looks like a callus yeah that's
it no but you said
wart and i saw it that big so then i was
like holy
is it her are you sure it's not just a
callus it's i think it's a war
yeah or it's no it's not bubbly that
doesn't have to be a bubbly that aren't
worth like a bubble
i don't know it looks like this
oh like a callus yeah maybe it's a
calorie
anyway i did read some tweets on i'm so
sorry to interrupt you
um i did see some tweets where they're
like bella thorns ruining you know
because that's like a sex worker
industry right
that a lot of kind of um not super
famous people use to get money
that she ruined the cap of how much you
can charge in a dm
yeah i was about to say all that for
sure yeah yeah that's what i read inside
ruin the cap what is that
like that the maximum amount that you
can charge me so previously
it was there was no cap it was unlimited
yeah you could have as
much tips or whatever as you want you
could charge however much you want
that's why she was charging
200 that was her bella's price
yeah but because of the backlash and
because of
the fundamentals only fans being
bombarded with refunds exactly the site
now has changed their their stuff to the
point where
they can only charge like the maximum
that someone can charge is 50
for exclusive content and they're
capping
chips at a hundred dollars why and they
so only fans is claiming they don't want
to make more money only fans is claiming
that it's unrelated to bella thorne
but sure they didn't want to deal with
the processing that's what it is
also i assume it's like like insurance
companies right if too much is trying to
get pulled back at once they just can't
afford it pretty crazy
also another thing that they change that
sex
workers are completely pissed about is
now they
instead of going from getting paid
weekly now it's monthly
and so they have everything to clear oh
yeah
because of the refunds and stuff exactly
that makes sense she really screwed a
whole
industry over the industry of like
non-famous
sex workers well it was bound to happen
right because a lot of payment
processing and all that
it shouldn't be paid out weekly that's
way too quick
well that's how they were handling it
capping the amount
for me they should just change the
amount of uh they should change the
process for refunds versus like capping
how much
you can deposit or like how much you can
buy
so like people want immediate refunds
right so they get chargebacks
but then in order for them to like not
make it so uh like a large sum they're
capping it at 50 bucks
they should that doesn't make any sense
to me yeah yeah
well that's the max and the max you
could donate is yeah so does that mean
you can donate like a hundred like ten
times if you want to
i don't know they just the wording is
just that they cap tips at a hundred
that's so crazy because on twitch you
can you don't have like you can [ __ ]
do whatever you want
there's people that'll like tip
thousands of dollars yeah
and then yeah so all that happened so
bella got a [ __ ]
ton of backlash obviously and so that's
when bella
was apologizing and she was like you
know i'm so sorry i joined the site
because i was researching a project
with this director apparently she was
gonna
she got this role with a new for a new
movie
by the director sean baker who did the
florida project and tangerine
and she said that she was planning on
putting her earnings into
her production company and towards
charity and that the only reason why she
joined it was
to research this role well the director
shawn baker comes out
and said nah folks i am not attached to
this
at all like the fact that she joined us
for research is false
she just wanted money yeah she he he
said i'm actually in development on two
features i put years of research and
love into and neither of these films
have anything to do with miss
thorne or only fans he said that the
only conversation that he had with her
about only fans is discussing a possible
collaboration in the far
future that would focus on her life and
the circumstances leading up to her
joining only fans so this is after the
fact yeah interesting after the fact
and then so yeah if she's just in
hot water for them i love how he [ __ ]
said novel
you lying yeah why don't you even bother
name dropping then why she could have
just been like yeah i'm researching for
a movie maybe she'd at least hit him up
first he would
back her up yeah or maybe that's not one
director you could always talk [ __ ] to
and everyone does and
like he never stands up for himself
until this one time
yeah so then she she ended like this is
one of her tweets of her apologizing she
said i wanted to bring attention to the
sights the more people on the site the
more likely of a chance to normalize the
stigmas
and in trying to do this i hurt you i
have risked my career
no you idiot you didn't [ __ ] fulfill
what you promised and then people wanted
a refund
if you just gave your titties out like
you said you would
well it wasn't that's false
advertisement out of the four golden
points
well it wasn't like that that added to
it definitely
but it was the fact that she joined the
site to begin with which is like
why like you're she's taking
opportunities away from others i don't
think it's how they viewed it i don't
think that's
a problem because youtubers can't get
mad that celebrities are joining youtube
sure it's like you're like they're like
saying what about the little guy it's
like what are you talking about there
are
unknown unknown girls on only fans that
are making millions of dollars that
aren't celebrities
and they're not taking away if a
celebrity joins they're just more p
people are just gonna spend more money
that's all it is like just because one
person is successful doesn't mean that
they're taking away from you yeah your
customers are your customers if they
like your product they're gonna stay
with you they're not gonna all of a
sudden go like okay i'm gonna stop
spending on this person
and spend on [ __ ] will smith's dick
so it's
that i think what's happening with and i
guess to bring it back to the youtube
example is when celebrities did start
joining on the algorithm algorithm and
all that stuff started really changing
and
trying to favor these celebrities so
yeah there is no problem with him
joining in that regard but i think in
the regard of what she ended up doing
and ultimately what ended up happening
yeah to youtube is that it just shifted
because now they're like
oh [ __ ] we have these eyeballs so let's
capitalize on this and let's cater to
that but to me it's like we live in a
free
marketplace right why aren't they
allowed to do this
like why is it only sacred for people
who
are unknown i think i think they are
allowed i think it is that they're a lot
i think it's just not fair the way that
companies now treat it where now they
they they put the little people off to
the side where they're like that's
actually one of the points of
um people on her twitter mentions like
replying to her apologizing
they were like okay we've been on only
fans for i don't know how many years and
but yet you've only been on it for one
week and now you get to meet with the
execs of
the the entire company like talk about
privilege so a lot of people are upset
about that like how come you're talking
to them and they won't even reply to my
emails
and yeah like that's that's yeah but
that's also called life too
unrealistic because we've been on
youtube for like 13 years we're small
fries right
and we don't even have a youtube rep and
i
get it because when will smith joined
jack black
joined all these people joined like they
come with
so much legitimacy right so i'm only
talking from a business perspective
it sucks that it happens and i get it
but it's also very unrealistic to expect
it to me it feels entitled to me it
feels like i say
yeah and then it's small forever yeah
it's like if you were the one that
became famous
and you were the one that became a
celebrity it's like you would do the
same thing
why is it that it it's because you are
the little one
so you feel entitled to having that type
of attention too that's kind of what was
happening in the early days and when
everyone was getting brand deals and
stuff it's like oh you sell out whatever
because exactly yeah i mean i do think
there's a certain amount though
of sensitivity coming into someone
else's
culture or whatever i mean that's the
same with like cultural appropriation or
whatever
but when these celebrities go and like
specifically i think of when vivo came
on to youtube
and these really legit music videos like
were the ones coming up in the
algorithms and stuff and then the
independent
music videos like i did feel some kind
of way about that if there was some kind
of like
say if uh like let the market speak for
itself
i'm always down for that for sure and
but if i'm coming into
say a site that's small like and i'm
bigger than whatever i'd be like hey i
if i even just give one kind of
scent of appreciation towards what
everyone else has built
and i publicly say that then i think
that those people on that platform will
feel
some sort of respect coming from like a
bella thorne
coming in and not and she's obviously
going to capitalize either way
yeah either way but acknowledging the
ecosystem which i think
would be big and maybe she wouldn't have
received a lot of backlash but i feel
you it's a free market because it feels
like she's coming in and exploiting the
situation
right right and it is [ __ ] up for the
girls because it's like yo man i've been
giving my [ __ ] [ __ ] up for this [ __ ]
for so long and then like they are
working hard you know they have to
maintain their customer base
they have to all all that [ __ ] and yeah
the novelty of a celebrity coming in and
then they're gonna show off their [ __ ]
that's gonna maybe distract their own
customer base and [ __ ] it all up and
it's kind of like [ __ ] you already make
millions of dollars why did you have to
come into my place
and [ __ ] this up for me that makes sense
yeah people were saying back to what you
were saying is like
if you just had a conversation with us
like the
the creators and stuff yeah the creators
on this site then you could have
approached this a lot better
but at the end of the day she should
have [ __ ] not false advertised
yeah if you showed your titties like you
said you would nobody would be in this
[ __ ] mess
dumbass that's the main point you lied
yeah
that's like a man come over and come buy
some joe's coffee
and then they go that's water
[ __ ] give me my money back
yeah and everyone came in on the same
day yeah huge grand opening
[Music]
you